well here's a look at what joe biden's
promised when it comes to
migrants he doesn't want detention
centers along the mexico border
he opposes the highly controversial
policy of locking up children
he also doesn't want parents and
children to be separated
he says he'll also halt efforts to build
donald trump's now infamous
border wall that money will instead be
used for better screaming of
screening of migrants funds will also go
towards helping migrants
arriving at the border biden's also
promised to gather with other regional
leaders within his first 100 days in
office
to come up with a more permanent
solution he's also promised changes
for migrants already in the u.s he's
expressed support
for dhaka a program meant to protect the
children of undocumented
immigrants he's also announced an
immigration reform bill which will
create a pathway to citizenship
for 11 million undocumented people let's
bring in
linda rivas who is the executive
director at las americas
immigrant advocacy center she joins us
now via skype from el paso in texas near
the border with mexico good to have you
with us
linda what do you make of of joe biden's
plans for
immigration do they go far enough
yes that's something that we are all
hopeful for
um that this will go further
um we right now what we're dealing with
under the trump
administration is some of the cruelest
policies that we have
ever seen implemented to essentially
stop asylum
so we know that the rebuilding has to
start immediately
and not only rebuilding but we also hope
to see expansion for protections for
people who need it
so at the very least you're hoping for a
more compassionate approach to the
the issue absolutely
uh compassionate humane uh moving away
from the
idea of immigrants and refugees as a
national security risk
and the united states treating starting
to treat people with true humanity
is something that we are strongly
advocating for
and to hear uh divided administration
begin to plan
for example to turn back the uh
mpp or remain in mexico program
where thousands of asylum seekers were
sent to mexico
into dangerous situations is it it's a
very promising start
what about this issue of of not wanting
uh to continue
to have anything to do with a policy
that separates uh
children from uh their parents
absolutely we need to stop this policy
and additionally start to reunite some
of these families
especially those families uh many of
them who have been
deported without their children and face
uh face indefinite separation these are
families that
you know we in el paso uh have
identified have been working with
um el paso unfortunately was the pilot
program for family separation
so we new families separated since 2017
we hope to bring them into the spotlight
we
hope that the biden administration will
begin to reunite these families to try
and restore
so much that they have lost and what
they have endured what about the
the contentious issue of of
financial help for migrants
yes well you know the the first step is
we need to figure out how to help
migrants in a way
where they are not forced into dangerous
situations
to migrate we know that the laws
of asylum that we already have in our
country
allow for asylum seekers to have a
process to work
we want to reject detention for
asylum seekers because that this is this
is important
for them to begin their to truly be
welcomed
into our country we believe that that is
that is where we need to start
as we said a few moments ago joe biden
is promising to gather with other
regional leaders within his uh first 100
days in office to
to hammer out some sort of long-term
solution and
what should that solution look like as
as far as
neighboring countries are concerned
absolutely well the responsibility has
to lie within the united states we saw
under the trump administration for far
too long that the pushing of asylum
seekers
into mexico um even into uh third
countries as the the third country
agreements allowed
for certain asylum seekers to be sent to
countries that have
essentially no existing asylum seeker
whatsoev
asylum system whatsoever so we
want immediately the the biden
administration to work with these
uh with these other countries but also
not lose sight
that people do need to migrate that they
are coming to the united states to seek
protection
and to stop uh you know putting the
responsibility on other countries but
instead
work together and be the united states
needs to be seen as true leaders in
welcoming
refugees not only in our neighboring
countries but this needs to be a message
to the world really good to talk to you
linda many thanks indeed for being with
us linda rivas there
executive director at las america las
americas the immigrant advocacy center